because being american is more than a
pride
we inherit it's the past we step into
and how we repair it welcome back to cbs
this morning that's inaugural poet
amanda gorman captivating the nation
yesterday with her performance of the
hill we climb
the poem drew inspiration from sources
ranging from the bible to the musical
hamilton
gorman the country's first national
youth poet laureate
is being praised for meeting the moment
with a work that's both hopeful
and realistic for there is always light
if only we're brave enough to see it if
only
we're brave enough to be it with her
poem
aptly named the hill we climb 22 year
old amanda gorman became the youngest
poet
to speak at a presidential inauguration
wednesday
in the norms and notions of what just is
isn't always just this
gorman's stirring performance was met
with a standing ovation
on a day for the history books former
president obama tweeted
amanda gorman delivered a poem that more
than met the moment
i don't just like poetry i love poetry
and i
live it gorman told us last week that
she learned about the inauguration
performance
in december i was sitting on it for a
really long time
even kind of nervous about telling my
mom because i knew she would want to
shout it from the rooftops because it
was just such an amazing opportunity
a nation of all people by all people
though it's hard to imagine
now performing did not come easily to
her
as a young child as a toddler growing up
i had a speech impediment
how long did you have that speech
impediment oh gosh i would say through
sophomore year of college when you have
to teach yourself
how to pronounce the american alphabet
when you have to teach yourself
over years how to say your own last name
you gain
a real appreciation for the musicality
um and the complexity of sound so often
people say wow it's amazing that you've
done all of this
despite your speech impediment i say
i've done all of it
because of that experience we the
successors of a country
and the time where a skinny black girl
descended from slaves and raised by a
single mother
can dream of becoming president
only to find herself reciting for one
i'm also struck by the fact that that
you said you would like to be yourself
president one day
oh yeah i'll be back you will
this will be the first rodeo but it
won't be the last one yeah
have you already made your campaign
plans i have
my independent hashtag is going to be
hashtag
commanda in chief because you know oh
that's awesome
play on words because that's what i do
that's great oh man and you know what
you can totally see it yes i think it
may happen
but i like how she said i'll be back
without arrogance some people can say
that you do i will like oh god they're
obnoxious
that's not how you feel about it my
reaction was of course you would of
course you could
for sure of course you will and and i
would not want to have to debate her
yeah the only controversial thing is she
pairs to she organizes her books by
color
i noticed yes that will divide some
americans yeah
as president that'll be the first
controversy and she really did meet the
moment yesterday yeah absolutely
she really did yeah absolutely we know
we're well here we didn't surprise us we
are not late to the amanda gorman party
he's done
amazing work for this broadcast and
we're very proud of our association with
her and and she delivered again